the covid-19 vaccines are by far the
best way to protect yourself and your
loved ones from the virus
anyone who isn't vaccinated should get
one as soon as possible to be protected
for the holidays and that includes 5 to
11 year olds who are now eligible for
the Pfizer vaccine
this is the Reuben report it's January
23rd 2023 and if you took Health advice
from that lady well good luck with all
of that we are live streaming on Rumble
and YouTube as well as locals of course
and if you want to play along during the
show join us at reubenreport.locals.com
and every day we have a live post game
show where you guys can question me
correct me yell at me or say nice things
fully up to you that's what we do right
after the show the link is right down
below Today's Show as we begin the week
is going to be an extension of sort of
what we were doing last week which is a
lot of stuff about the world economic
forum and how its tentacles have
basically reached into every Western
democracy and have us all doing a whole
bunch of stuff that's probably against
our national interest but for some
reason we feel the need well not you not
me but the collective we to listen to
these lunatics like screaming Al Gore
and absolutely awful uh John Kerry or
very bizarre angry little girl Greta
thundberg etc etc the cast of characters
does not end uh but we're going to go
into a bit more about what's going on
over at the wef which we think it just
wrapped up it just wrapped up they're
probably still sucking the natural
resources out of the area and worshiping
children or whatever they do but yeah
the thing itself wrapped up so we're
gonna cover a little bit of the end of
it some of the media reaction to it
and then how that's sort of reflective
of everything going on in our country
right here and of course I'm going to
give you some good stuff at the end
because good things are happening and if
these are the best they got if the
Sunbirds and the carries and the Gores
and the Albert borlas are the best that
they got I really do think we're gonna
be okay so here we go so first let's
start with Greta foundberg and you know
Greta thundberg how dare you uh this
little girl who screams about climate
change and who's aging horribly uh
because her whole life is based on
nonsense uh anyway we played last week
her being arrested in Germany and there
was a clip that went viral around the
world was seen millions and millions of
times of her being arrested protesting
something in Germany mean German police
officers carrying her away it was very
scary
of course then we found the other video
and the other video shows that the
entire thing was staged completely
staged her smiling with the police
officers beforehand literally them like
softly holding her on the wrist just
completely ridiculous well anyway Greta
ends up at the world economic forum and
she got questioned by some real
journalists and I have to say when I can
say the world the word journalist or
journalist without air quotes it's an
absolute pleasure and I've given them a
lot of credit but I want to continue the
guys over at Rebel media up in Canada it
is an independent Outlet I believe
started by Ezra Levant who's a buddy of
mine who's been on the show many times
they've got Avi yemeni and a whole bunch
of other people who are out there doing
actual journalism and world at the world
economic economic Forum they are running
down the street getting microphones in
these people's faces asking them real
questions anyway Ezra got in the face of
how dare you Greta thundberg and asked
her about her staged arrest
here for Rebel news I'm standing outside
the CNBC Studio the same one where the
vice president threatened to clock our
friend Avi yamini of course it's where
all the vvips pop by to give their
propaganda message dutifully transcribed
by the media party here how dare you
you're arrested chairman Coal Mine how
many times did you rehearse it because
it looks staged is it true how many
times should you rehearse your arrest
Greta
how many times did you film your arrest
and why was it staged that way Greta
considering you've not spent much time
in school how do you know so much about
climate change
do you think at least the fact these
delegates take private jets is a Bad
Thing against you know what you believe
in
all of this could be done via Zoom so
surely
surely you should be encouraging all the
delegates especially the likes of U.S
Special Envoy John Kerry for climate uh
especially for climate change surely you
should be saying to these people you
should be doing this via Zoom with a
much smaller carbon footprint surely
would you say you're a child actor
are you a child actor or an expert how
would you describe yourself
it's just great stuff from Rebel and I
know it's like jarring when you see a
journalist
going after the people who they should
go after and asking the right questions
you almost don't know what to do with it
because of course that's not going to
come from anyone at the New York Times
or CNN or anything else as a matter of
fact we showed you videos last week I
think it was a CNBC journalist
interviewing Albert borla the the head
of Pfizer basically being like when can
we get the flu covid combo vaccine maybe
it was Bloomberg oh yeah it was
Bloomberg TV but the point is it's like
they carry water for these people and
then you have a couple people like Ezra
that are out there asking the right
questions what's so interesting about
Greta I mean the smugness and
dismissiveness and she's definitely not
starving I don't know they fatten all
these people up at the world economic
Forum between her and Al Gore and the
rest of them but what's interesting
about her is at the very minimum you
know instead of just walking quietly
with that smug smile on her face why
couldn't she just say you know actually
you do make a decent point about the the
private planes because the carbon
footprint of this thing is extraordinary
and these people are all flying here
private they are all taking up
tremendous tremendous resources these
are Ultra rich people who you can't even
imagine the level of that these
people are doing there you just can't on
top of the 2500 an hour prostitutes and
everything else right so why couldn't
she just say actually you know what I
will answer that one question that's
actually a decent point and perhaps next
year we'll do it by Zoom or perhaps next
year we'll figure out some other way to
have a series of flights instead of
everyone flying in privately but it's
all part of the grift so let's continue
with the grift because what really it's
the greatest gift of all time that they
are trying to pull off these are people
who have who enjoy all of the luxuries
of living in Western Society right they
have free speech they have freedom of
Association they they have all made
most of the people there millions and
millions or in Al Gore's case hundreds
of millions uh John Kerry's case
hundreds of millions of dollars through
capitalism through all of the things
that they've done in these free
societies yet they have this meeting
annually in Davos to discuss how they
can destroy capitalism how they can
destroy Free Speech Western societies
free thought all of that stuff so here
is uh Slovenian foreign minister Tanja
fujon I think I got that one right uh
calling for countries to uh really stop
caring about themselves and bow to the
New World Order
we have to take care of the rules of the
international law and really respect
that and not change it in a time when
there are countries that choose the way
not to respect them and Russia choose
that way so we have countries that are
respecting the rules and we have
countries that are respecting their
national interests going beyond the
rules and that is what is happening and
we have to take into consideration the
world order that's a really
extraordinary statement for a foreign
minister of any country to be saying
you're respecting the rules if you're
respecting the world economic forums
rules they are not some sort of binding
organization
completely not uh they're a group of
Rich Elites who send out their minions
to all of our countries to try to change
our policies but they don't set rules
they'd like to set rules they'd like to
set far more than rules and they'd like
to take a whole bunch of us out while
they do it uh but she seems to think
that their rules are more important than
the country's own National interest
well frankly Slovenia lady I think that
slovenians should be in charge of what
happens in Slovenia okay
I think that's a pretty Slovenian idea
and I think Americans should be more in
charge of what's going on with Americans
than a Slovenian foreign minister and
her sold out Cadre a blizzard people
okay that's where I sit on this thing
but they continued because not only are
they trying to confuse you about climate
change and they want to make sure you
follow their rules well they've also got
to make everything gay okay they have to
gay up the whole thing hold on let me
loosen my wrist a little they have to
make this whole thing gay okay you have
to be gay and if you're not gay they'll
gay you up they'll put it in the water
whatever they have to do they're going
to gay it up we have to get this gay
stuff out there video it's about making
sure that people are seen in the
mainstream media in day-to-day life and
I think that's another opportunity where
we have the corporate world to play a
really important role it's in this as
one of our colleagues said in another
Forum that we were in the other day the
hearts and Minds part of this and that
is to make fake LGBT
people the community visible when you
are talking about your product you know
visible in your imagery
um you know we can make sure that your
products are centered towards
does anyone think we need more of this
are you guys not getting enough gay
imagery throughout the day
it's so stupid first off gay is maybe 10
of people maybe maybe maybe I have no
problem with gay people I'm married to
one okay but the point is they don't
have to the majority doesn't always have
to cater everything to the minority but
these people are obsessed with that
they're obsessed with that we should
really think about that at a
psychological level why is that they
want everything to be fabulous
anyway here's a crazy woman in a hat
also
leaders
we have a deeply wounded Spirit as a
people that is in desperate need of
healing and restoration and we must look
to our Almighty Creator to find our
proper place in humanity our proper
place
all right lady you're wounded but I'm
pretty sure whatever is going to fix you
ain't gonna fix me just stay out of our
lives that is it crazy hat lady uh
Tucker had a nice little take on the
ending of the world economic Forum they
brought in some entertainers at the end
and there was this incredible floutest
she was a floutist without a flout take
a look
time to check in with our lizard
overlords in Davos Switzerland what are
they up to well this
[Music]
oh thank you for watching
yeah those people run the world
they're so impressive
[Music]
what a bunch of freaks
okay I want a hit on what Tucker said
there at the end those people around the
world question mark I think look it all
seems scary and they are plotting
against us I mean they really are and
they do send these Stooges like Justin
Trudeau and Gavin Newsom they send these
people into Western democracies but I'm
telling you guys I really really believe
this this this is not the best of the
best that we're up against these are
incompetent buffoons who idea whose
ideas are so anti-human that they cannot
win we just need to be a little bit
braver pushing back on it we just need
to expose them more and that's why they
want censorship of course but a lot of
the stuff that they have pushed over the
last couple years is being exposed in
real time and good people not crazy
right-wing Maniacs good decent people
who are apolitical who just want to go
about living their lives they're
figuring it out so this is really
extraordinary you may remember a video
that we played last week where Ezra
Levan and Avi yemeni two of the Rebel
news guys where they got at Davos they
got in the face of Albert borla and he
is the Pfizer CEO and they asked him
about the efficacy of vaccines and when
did he know they didn't work and why are
they continuing to push it Etc et cetera
so first off that video you can take a
look at the Tweet here this is a tweet
from Avi yemeni this video has now been
banned on Facebook Instagram and YouTube
the world economic Forum wants it
scrubbed and their lackeys are happy to
oblige thank you Elon Musk for not
caving 7.3 million views and Counting
the public wants answers so that video
on Twitter now last I saw as of this
morning had something like 20 million
views already now we also did put it up
on our YouTube channel and it is still
up okay I don't know if they think maybe
I'm too big of a Target so if you take
me out you've now you know you've
Butterfly Effect affected this whole
thing and it's just bigger and bigger
and bigger but ours is still up and as I
tweeted yesterday I will not take that
video down this is one of the reasons
that we are doing in our thing with
Rumble first off I know Rumble would
never ask me to do that but we are sure
that our stuff will stay right there and
if
if YouTube and Facebook are taking down
videos of journalists simply asking
questions you don't even have to like
Rebel you can think Ezra is an idiot you
may you may be Albert borla's second
cousin's nephew's uncle but you should
understand that there is absolutely no
reason that video should be taken down
so let's just quickly show you a snippet
once again if you didn't see it we're
going to show snippet again we'll see if
they come after me of that very video Mr
borla can I ask you when did you know
that the vaccines didn't stop
transmission how long did you know that
without saying it publicly thank you
very much I'm sorry to that question
yeah I'm not taking the video down we
just played it again I will get every
well-known well-powered lawyer on the
planet to fight YouTube and Facebook and
everything else if they try to do it and
even if they do it this is exactly why
rumble.com reubenreport I hope you're
watching our videos over there okay so
super interesting though that they're
taking these videos down and it just
goes to show that everything that we
learned over the last couple months
related to the Twitter files and
governments working with tech companies
don't worry I'm not getting an
information I'm not getting information
from the boss man it was just my piece
fell out of my ear that I can hear the
clips on uh we know what's going on here
right you get it you get it we've seen
it all with the Twitter files and then a
video like that gets out there and then
suddenly YouTube and Facebook want to
take it down so what else is going on
here well well the other piece of that
comes with all of this is that we are
learning every day more and more that
the vaccines did not work that they lied
about the science that they push things
on people who did not need vaccines
whether they were you know healthy 25
year old guys who otherwise were not
going to get sick maybe would get sick a
little bit but then move on like
everything else is hap you know in the
world you get the flu you move on okay
life's fine but they wanted to vaccinate
children all of these things and now
we're seeing all of this stuff about
vaccine injuries and the heart attacks
and people passing out and a whole bunch
more and they can't honestly answer
those questions right because they'd all
end up in jail probably if they honestly
answered it so the gift all of the
people all of the people whether it's
the people that Pfizer or the people at
the government or people of the WF or
all the Hollywood actors all of the
people who push mandates who pushed
vaccines they had no idea what they were
talking about or they were doing it for
genuinely nefarious reasons they all
have to protect each other because if
one guy admits it then it's dominoes
right you're going to take out everybody
one of the fascinating things about all
of this is that did you know you
probably did because you're a pretty
bright person that Pfizer wanted
immunity from vaccine lawsuits and
basically got granted it by our
government here's Tucker talking about
that one of the first things Pfizer did
before it sold its coveted shot was to
ensure it had total immunity from
lawsuits they made the government sign
contracts acknowledging the long-term
effects of the shots could be dangerous
but they couldn't be sued for it imagine
if you're a carpenter I'm going to build
your house if it falls down on you I
can't be sued because Congress will
protect me
wow that's a pretty good deal can we get
that
so now authorities are investigating
whether the shock causes Strokes in
people over the age of 65.
the weird thing is we've been getting
news about the effects of the Pfizer
shot for more than a year now and no one
seems to have thought to ask the CEO of
Pfizer Albert borley who's gotten
incredibly Rich from those shots what he
thinks of it
you really need to understand this
Pfizer warned the government of the
United States that there could be
long-term side effects and of course
there would be as I keep saying if you
watch any commercial on television I
don't have cable anymore but I remember
when I used to watch things with
commercials and every single commercial
would be an antidepressant pill or some
other you know you got your eyelashes
are too long or what else they got your
earlobes are too short all of these
things and they're gonna you take a pill
it's gonna somehow fix that but you're
going to get hysterical diarrhea and
thoughts of suicide and vomiting you're
gonna punch your grandmother a whole
bunch of wacky but for some reason
with the Pfizer I think did I make up
the punch your grandma thing all right I
might have made that one up but for some
reason with the Pfizer and moderna
vaccines you they push these commercials
everywhere and they never said anything
about side effects how bizarre it is
quite bizarre but it wasn't just
you can't blame just the the drug
companies for this you can't just blame
Pfizer and moderna because they need
cohorts they need a partner to pull a
scam like this on everybody we found
this video they what they need are
government actors who will scare the
hell out of people so that the
government can make contracts with these
big Pharma companies and they can pull
the giant grift of all time right in
front of our eyes check this video out
this is from this is the Australian
government this is not Pfizer this is an
Australian government video in 2021 uh
well you'll see
hahaha
[Music]
authorized by the Australian government
Canberra
what happened to Crocodile Dundee he
would have never he would have this is a
knife he would have yeah you got the
point
um so they needed that was the
government doing that to their own
people get vaccinated now it turns out
vaccines don't work scaring the high
hell out of people so that they could do
the bidding of the vaccine companies I
know it all sounds dystopian we're in
dystopia people but good things are
happening one of the things that I
mentioned last week is that New Zealand
prime minister this woman Jacinda Arden
she was one of the worst I mean she was
like true doe level Evil when it came to
lockdowns and scaring the hell out of
people and everything else she has
stepped down in this last week but let's
flash back for a second I got a couple
videos of her you've seen some of these
uh this is her about a year ago talking
about two different classes of people
because if you don't get vacs they're
gonna have to come for you
so you basically said this is going to
be like well it's almost like you
probably don't see it like this the two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvaccidated
you'd have all these rights if you are
vaccinated that is what it is so yep yep
people started to protest even a place
like New Zealand where things are pretty
good and people aren't used to
protesting their government but people
did not want to get vaccinated they
certainly did not want to be forced to
be vaccinated and this was the same
woman you may remember the video who
around that very same time said that we
are the only source of truth if you
don't hear it from us it is not true
that is almost a Verbatim quote so you
know what happened the people in New
Zealand got out on the streets take a
look
thank you
so they got out on the streets and then
what happened well about four days ago
she stepped down she is gone she is no
longer the prime minister of New Zealand
and uh here's a little video of her just
from a day or two ago and look she's
happier already because I guess she's
maybe stepping away from her job as
full-time evil Overlord
for the first time in a long time last
night but he's still a range of emotions
so I of course feel
um you know sad but uh also I do have a
sense
all right while she's sleeping well
she's sad that she can't ruin
everybody's lives again and here's just
a little throwaway video this is where
the conspiracy theorists of the internet
because there are videos of this sort of
thing happening to zielinski and a whole
bunch of other uh world leaders you just
make of this what you will this is her
about a year ago
foreign
I leave that one to you guys so what's
the point why are we showing you all
this we're showing you all this because
we're actually winning and they're
losing and it's not just because some of
them are resigning and it's not just
because more and more people are waking
up to the nonsense and people are
realizing what what Outsourcing your
individual Choice does to society it's
that people are generally speaking
fighting the system in a new way they
really really are people are tuning out
of mainstream media they're tuning into
shows like this and we can do it and
then people get braver right what that's
the thing that I'm always talking about
that bravery begets bravery so Ezra
Levant he's going out there he's being
brave now that video has been seen 20
million times and he'll get braver and
then you know what some people will
donate to rebel and their operation will
expand and yes and the government of
Canada will try to shut down their bank
accounts and a whole bunch more but it's
like the March is on guys it really is
gone but what do I always say about all
this the the simple truth is we can not
forget the hysteria there's a reason I'm
showing you that Australian government
video it's like we can't just think that
it was the it was these pharmaceutical
companies it was the people in power and
those people in power in governmental
power but there also our celebrity class
because there were
an endless amount of celebrities saying
complete nonsense and for some reason we
live in a culture where people care what
celebrities say right these are actors
for the most part and actors act they
don't actually do anything they act
they're not actually doing the things
that they're pretending to do they're
pretending that's how it works and we
this video was going around over the
weekend and I thought it was worth
seeing again this is Tom Hanks beloved
Forest Gump Tom Hanks Wilson on the
island he went to the moon what else did
he do he burbs that movie The Burbs give
me one more give me one more which one
Polar Express he's been around the block
this Tom Hanks guy done a lot of stuff
right but listen to him in 2021 talking
about vaccines
I don't get it
I I simply do not get it it is literally
the least you can do and if you want to
if anybody wants to build up an argument
about doing the least they can do I
wouldn't trust them with a driver's
license I mean when you drive a car you
got to obey speed the speed limit you
got to use your turn signal you got to
avoid hitting pedestrians if you can't
do those three things then I get it you
shouldn't be driving a car if you can't
wear a mask and wash your hands in
Social distance I I don't understand I I
got no respect for you man
maybe you should stop going to Tom Hanks
movies like I don't really mean to make
this about Tom Hanks is he is he the
worst person in the world but that
notion right like if you don't wear a
mask and you don't uh wash your hands
and socially distance things that all
turn out to be nothing yes washing your
hands is fine okay but social distancing
was nonsense wearing a mask was complete
nonsense and when you even literally if
you go right now go to your CVS or your
Walgreens or whatever drugstore you go
to go to the mask section and look at
the boxes and the boxes all say these
masks don't stop covid right so he had
no idea what he was talking about but he
was saying if the people who don't
follow the system and what he's saying
there is the system's been really good
to me right the guy's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars he's a massive Elite
Superstar and again I'm not saying that
he himself is the worst guy in the world
because he probably isn't that would be
he probably isn't but all of these
people
carried water for a system that was
crashing down on the rest of us and that
is not good and we cannot forget it so
speaking of a guy that I wish I could
forget but here we are playing a clip of
him here's Don Lemon over at CNN 2021
and uh he has much of that Tom Hanks
sort of attitude when it comes to
unbaxed Americans
the people who are not getting vaccines
who are believing the lies on the
internet instead of science it's time to
start shaming now what else or leave
them behind
because they are keeping the majority of
Americans behind
okay so it turns out we were right we
actually believed in the science more
than you did we showed some skepticism
which is a key part of scientific
inquiry and you should be shamed on
Lemon I mean you were ashamed in that
they fired you from your evening show
and they put you on the morning show and
that's what they do with the people
before the next thing which the next
thing is firing you all together but you
should be shamed but but really if you
think about it someone like Don Lemon if
CNN was an outfit of Journalism and
again it's not you guys know that he
should be fired immediately I don't mean
that in a cancel culture sense of things
right like unjustly going for someone
because they said something that
offended me I mean it in terms of what
is your job Don Lemon as an as a
broadcaster you're certainly not a
journalist I know you always say you are
but you're a broadcaster your job is to
tell people something roughly
approximate to the truth and not only
can you not do that you were
intentionally because you're you're not
that bright you were intentionally
driving people to hate other people and
of course it turned doubt that you had
the whole thing backwards the entire
time so Don Lemon would never walk back
his comment right he would never do it
because they just keep lying and nobody
ever gets fired so why should Don Lemon
sit down and be like guys you know what
I really did uh screw this thing up it
turns out the vaccines don't really work
it turns out I shouldn't be shaming
people and actually if anything this
should be a major mayor culpa by me and
of course he was also there talking to
Chris Cuomo who had to step down from
CNN in absolute shame so there's
something sort of beautiful here but
look how the media and this is why it
just continues why does this never
happen because the machine protects the
people who always defend the machine
check out this headline this is going to
make your head explode I saw this one on
Saturday CBS News as the super rich
Gather in Davos online conspiracy
theorists make bizarre claims that the
world is run by the super rich one more
time the super rich are gathering
everyone's admitting that but it's a
bizarre claim to think that the world is
run by the super rich you are telling
you the whole purpose of the conference
is how they can get the that they
want done across the world I mean it is
absolutely insane but the media lies
about everything and you know it you may
have seen this uh I know you guys don't
watch corporate media that much God
bless you uh so this may be the first
time you're seeing some of this over the
weekend there were massive massive
Summer of Love 2020 like riots in
Atlanta okay antifa which is a fascist
organization it is an arm of the
Democrat Party period there is no doubt
when they want violence on the streets
they somehow get it to antifa and these
people always burn down democrat-run
cities
because they're not that bright people
do it anyway antifa is basically burning
down Atlanta over the weekend it was it
was absolutely insane we're going to
show you a couple of videos of this but
watch how the media frames all of this
so it doesn't even matter why they were
doing it I'm not I'm not going to get
into any of the defensive antifa or any
reason you'll see a little something
none of that matters the point is a
bunch of masked thugs are burning down
using flash bombs burning things up
breaking windows at least now Fox 5 in
Atlanta covers these protests take a
look over here if you pan over I want to
show you this is what they were handing
out at that protest so it was a largely
peaceful protest where they just wanted
what they're calling justice uh for to
to for two
so sorry
uh and right now uh you'll see basically
they want uh justice for him
want Justice for this guy that's what
we're really going to focus on they're
burning down the whole city I can't
pronounce the guy's name it doesn't even
matter it literally does not matter
whether whatever happened to that guy
it's completely irrelevant if something
bad happens in society and something
unjust happens it does not give you a
right to burn down a city we all used to
agree about that sort of thing but now
we don't now if you think that was
bizarre okay now watch CNN covering this
they have a guest on in Atlanta who is
some sort of journalist in Atlanta and
he doesn't want us to use the word
Violet for the people that are violently
Burning Down The City from from the
standpoint of of the protesters
um but as as even the chief himself said
this is a small group
um this isn't this is also Within this
defend the forest movement
um there are no leaders so people go off
and do their own things that doesn't
just make them justifiable but I I do
think that you know you keep using these
words violent violent violent violent
um and it gives the impression I mean
the only violence that that or the only
acts of violence against people that I
saw were actually police tackling
protesters
hmm and you've been there you've been
how profoundly embarrassing for CNN you
know they used to say the most trusted
name in news how profoundly embarrassing
first off a small group of people can do
a whole bunch of bad stuff this thing
about small seems to be the the left's
new line on everything right Joe Biden
just had a small amount of documents
that were illegally taken okay but it's
not about the size of the amount of
documents and these it's a small amount
of people burning down the whole city if
it was a little it was a medium amount
we'd be a little more upset about it no
a whole a small amount of people can do
a real a bunch of really bad stuff also
at the end there though it's only the
police officers that are attacking
people these people were literally
smashing Windows burning buildings and a
whole bunch more absolutely ridiculous
just ridiculous they want a police
language they want you to see something
with your own eyes and believe something
completely insane but they've been doing
this to us for a long long time remember
those fiery but mostly peaceful full
protests of 2020
. Christine Laura what you're seeing
behind me is one of multiple locations
that have been burning in Kenosha
Wisconsin over the course of the night a
second night since Jacob Blake was seen
shot in the back seven times by a police
officer and what you are seeing now
these images came and come in stark
contrast to what we saw over the course
of the daytime hours in Kenosha and into
the early evening which were largely
peaceful demonstrations in the guys
during the day they're largely peaceful
they're hanging out they're just saying
stuff sure at night they burn down the
whole city and they always burn down to
Pep Boys they always Target them Pep
Boys I don't know if it's just maybe
that's a numbers thing there's a lot of
targets and Pep Boys but they'll always
burn down you find a Pep Boys these
people want to burn you down I guess
there there's a lot of gas related
things and flammable things at a Pep
Boys and they always got to take out the
Target first what they want to do in the
name of social justice to steal all the
flat screen TVs because you wouldn't
want those to melt obviously that goes
without saying
um but yes they're largely peaceful so
they excuse the violence
that you can think what you want about
Blake being shot it's irrelevant you
cannot take vigilante justice into your
own hands and Destroy things and that's
why they always say violence against
things is not violence that's literally
what these people say and also they have
no leader so we can't really be upset
it's a bunch of people with no leader
that's actually scarier and amorphous
blob rampaging throughout Society
destroying things and we're also going
to say that it's not violent but
violence
rioting vandalism it's not just in
Atlanta wait we're gonna do more with
Atlanta right now no we're done with
Atlanta yeah we got more from Atlanta
here's more fruit here's more
hey can you guys hear us
the state trooper was injured in a
shooting and if you're taking a look at
video now I can hear it in my ear uh
that is just some of the moments that
you could see that uh protesters were
throwing bricks at what I believe to be
the Atlanta police uh the Atlanta police
foundation
um the Atlanta oh hey turn around okay
someone actually it looks like
flash bombs attacking the Atlanta police
Federation every one of those people
should be arrested fortunately at the
end the Atlanta police did get in there
and they arrested a whole bunch of
people so that is good but the fact that
this is going on again these These are
always democrat-run cities
always democrat-run cities and there is
a connection there that ain't a
coincidence okay and it is violence when
you attack a building and break Windows
it really is that is a type of violence
uh and these people need to pay and they
need they need to be held to the highest
standard of the law and should have the
the lock and key should be thrown at him
the whole freaking thing because
otherwise it is not going to stop and
you know how you know it's not going to
stop because it's also happening in
other cities because there was also a
big riot in Boston Massachusetts over
the weekend and this is rather
extraordinary so here is uh
representative congresswoman Kathleen
Clark she's Massachusetts congresswoman
and she's the Democrat whip she's a
pretty powerful Democrat and she tweeted
this out yesterday last night my
daughter was arrested in Boston
Massachusetts I love Riley and this is a
very difficult time in the cycle of joy
and pain in parenting this will be
evaluated by the legal system and I am
confident in in that process
now I want to point out once again she
said that Riley is her daughter do we
have a picture of her daughter Riley
ah so that is her daughter Riley Riley
and I don't mean to be a dick about it
as I often say is a dude that is a dude
who now says that he is a chick named
Riley and the mother there the Democrat
whip is going along along for this
hallucination now this is interesting
because you may remember during the last
presidential campaign Joe Biden a very
confused mumbling pandering Joe Biden
went to some gay conference and he told
these people that it is not if you get
arrested it is not what is on your birth
certificate the gender on your birth
certificate that will send you to say a
male prison or a female prison it's what
gender you identify as so this is very
hopeful for Riley who will hopefully for
Riley and for that lady end up in a
female prison so many of them and so yes
and by the way in prison in prison the
determination should be that you your
sexual identity is defined by what you
say it is not what in fact the prison
says it is and in that case you should
be entitled also to OGBYN anyway you
didn't ask that question but you're not
likely to either I guess I mean the man
cannot complete a sentence it's just
absolutely incredible but there you have
the president of the United States
saying whatever prison you want to go to
sure oh we arrested you for raping 20
women but now you say you're a chick
okay we'll throw you in with the women
again and then by the way these guys
continue to rape and maim and murder and
a whole bunch more so this is very
exciting in this case because Riley
hopefully will be arrested although you
know as the son or and or daughter of a
Democrat she or he is probably going to
get off on this thing that was funny you
know a certain way also
um
you got it you got it uh but what this
woman Catherine Clark doesn't perhaps
understand when you when you go along
with the delusions of young people right
and don't deal with the truth straight
on and all of those things uh you're
gonna grow up you're gonna set up these
people to be in a world that makes no
sense and perhaps that is why Riley he
or she is out there doing whatever she
or he is doing on the streets of Boston
but Katherine Catherine Clark uh she was
you may remember this I think we play
this this is a couple months ago her
kids are waking up freaking out about
climate change so you just watch this
clip and note how these things are all
connected the the psychological
condition related to the violence the
nonsensical ideas related to the truth
and much more
but they've also given us a model to
become our own leaders and let me tell
you what it means to to me coming in as
a different generation I remember my
middle child waking up with nightmares
over concern around climate change all
right so Catherine's son or daughter or
son and daughter whatever it is I'm not
sure if Riley's the middle child but she
is a woman that is spreading ideas in
her home and then throughout society as
a politician that would lead children to
having nightmares about climate change
and then next thing you know your
daughter son is out on the streets of
Boston
breaking windows or doing whatever the
hell he or she is doing and then
thankfully you have a president with
dementia who wants to send them into the
opposite prison then their genitals
dictate that is literally a sentence
that has never been said in the history
of humanity before it's just so insane
so now let's get to the good part of
this the good part of this is that
throughout history guys there have been
bad ideas there's there have been
fascists and Communists and socialists
and Nazis and a whole bunch of other bad
people and then good people start saying
things that are true you stop
participating in the lie you stand up
and you say I am here I have worth and I
am not going to pretend anymore that you
are good or valuable just because you
guilt me into thinking something okay
you know who's a good person she was a
great person I wish we still had her can
we maybe work on the cloning thing let's
talk to somebody in the UK about cloning
her here's Margaret Thatcher on
responding to socialists right
responding to these types of people who
would otherwise give us endless chaos
imagine a labor canvasser talking on the
doorstep to those East German families
when they settled in on freedom side of
the war
you'll want to keep more of the money
you earn I'm afraid that's very selfish
we shall want to tax that away
you want to earn shares in your firm you
can't have that the state has to earn
your firm
you want to choose where to send your
children to school that's very divisive
send your child where we tell you
if it goes into trouble with labor is
that they're just not at home with
freedom
socialists don't like Ordinary People
choosing for they might not choose
socialism
you get it I know you guys get it and
that is exactly what we need and what I
believe is happening right now as I have
said for the last couple weeks I think
through the through first it starts in
Florida the Florida blueprint that is
now being exported throughout the
country the blueprint that Ron DeSantis
really started by saying no more of this
nonsense I am the chief executive of
this state I am going to do what is
right by my people now other Governors
throughout the country are starting to
see that right and some Governors even
though obviously we didn't get everybody
that you might have wanted in the
midterms some Governors new ones like
Sarah Huckabee Sanders in Arkansas are
doing all sorts of things with school
choice and getting wokism out of school
which is exactly what's going on here
which is why I describe it as a
blueprint that has to be exported you
saw we talked about it last week Kim
Reynolds in Iowa going full school
choice vouchers for students but when
you listen to Margaret Thatcher so this
is someone across the pond about 40
years ago talking about how socialist
don't like choice they don't like you
decide where your kids go to school they
don't want they don't want you to have
more of your money and all those things
and they'll reverse it on you to make it
seem that you're the selfish one if you
want to think about where you have more
options where your kids go to school if
you want to keep more of your dollars so
it's the same themes
but we defeated the Soviet Union and she
had a little something to do with that
so I think we can defeat this thing that
is happening right now so what we need
are a series of good people to get
involved and what I think is going to
happen is that there's going to be a
really decent crop of Republicans coming
up and Will some of them fail us along
the way of course will they ever get
everything that you want done done no
but the the world does not Bend to your
will but on the margins we can hopefully
change it a little bit for the better so
one of those people who most likely is
going to run I've interviewed her a few
times I think she's really really decent
uh is Nikki Haley and she was on Fox
being asked whether she's about to make
an announcement we are in the New Year
how are those tea leaves looking are you
going to run for president well I'm not
going to make an announcement here but
when you're looking at a run for
president you look at two things you
first look at does the current situation
push for new leadership
the second question is am I that person
that could be that new leader yes we
need to go in a New Direction and can I
be that leader yes I think I can be that
leader I was as Governor I took on a
hurting state with double-digit
unemployment and we made it the Beast of
the southeast as Ambassador you know I
took on the world when they tried to
disrespect us and I think I showed what
I'm capable of at the United Nations so
do I think I could be that leader yes
but we are still working through things
and we'll figure it out I've never lost
a race I said that then I'd still say
that now I'm not going to lose now but
the reason I wanted to show you that
clip is because I happen to like Nikki
and I really think she's a decent person
I know some of the most trumpian bass
does not like her for whatever reason I
think they feel like she didn't support
Trump after January 6 or something to
that effect and everyone can make their
own judgment calls on all of those
things but the point is she really did
like the facts are the fact she turned
South Carolina around for sure she was
an incredible U.S ambassador to the U.N
under Trump right getting Trump's
policies across and we did not go to
Crazy Wars under Trump or under her and
I think she would just be another good
voice in the mix so what I really want
to see more than anything is I want to
see a whole bunch of people who are
decent get involved and I think that
that's what we're going to start seeing
but what it will all come down to what
it will all come down to is whether Ron
DeSantis is going to run and I do not
know I do not know but I know the
machine fears him now more than they
fear Trump last week we talked about
that article was it in New York Magazine
or New York times one of them about how
Donald Trump hated the media and that
was bad but Rhonda sandis is much worse
he's much worse because he ignores the
media oh yeah it was by a guy named
Peter Baker from The New York Times so
they know DeSantis is the real threat
because as I always say he's Hitler with
a calculator meaning they're going to
call any Republican Hitler and a racist
and a white supremacist and all that
stuff but DeSantis has all the receipts
of the incredible things that are being
done here in Florida by the way so I
think this morning Florida's
unemployment despite the craziest
natural disaster
in the last decade in America hurricane
Ian is now down to 2.5 percent Miami is
the safest city in the United States
there's a whole bunch of good stuff here
but I don't have to belabor the point
the point is that the media is going to
really try to confuse everyone about Ron
DeSantis and watch
MSNBC The televised mental institution
known as MSNBC here's Joe Scarborough
Scarborough trying to give DeSantis
advice as if he likes Ron DeSantis you
gotta love this my guess is just all of
us talking right now my guess is
DeSantis says wait a second why do I go
to the meat grinder that chewed up and
spit out 16 Republicans politically why
don't I let Trump run again
I I'll serve out my term
I'll end up with you know 80 approval
ratings among Republicans and then in 26
I just opened my presidential campaign
and I don't have to even take on deal
with this yeah the champ right I I think
that's probably what he's thinking in
Tallahassee because I think he knows he
does not want to cross Donald Trump on a
debate stage
you really need to understand this guys
this is the machine showing you the
early signal they're showing their hand
if you really are paying attention they
want Trump and they don't want DeSantis
right they want Trump because they've
been through that before they took out
Trump once and they'll figure out ways
to take them out again DeSantis is much
more difficult for these guys that's
absolutely true otherwise he has no
reason to say that right he has no
reason to say that does he still pretend
to be a conservative does he say he's a
conservative anymore I don't even know
what I don't even know what he is I mean
he's literally nothing he's whatever you
want him to be
um but
again I don't know if DeSantis is going
to run but you can just see the way the
machine operates and by the way I will
give because I really do try to give
people credit where credit is due at
some level
is it possible that Trump would just
demolish DeSantis in the debates Trump
is he's a television guy he's a good
debater although actually in some of
those debates against Biden he was not
phenomenal he was a little jumpy and
sort of I thought unnecessarily angry in
some of them or whatever but he
obviously he's really good when there's
a whole bunch of people I think as it
gets to a smaller amount of people he
maybe isn't quite as good but yes did he
Crush Marco Rubio and demolish Ted Cruz
and just you know blow out everybody out
of the water of course he did is
debating desantis's strong point perhaps
not perhaps not but governing is so we
also all of us going forward will have
to decide do we want someone who is just
good for the TV clicks and the viral
moments or do we want someone who's
actually competent in all of the things
that I'd like to believe that we are
supporting them for that's what we're
all going to have to think about but I
get the inclination to just make it
about who's the biggest TV star and if
that really is what it is then it's
Trump and again I like Trump I voted for
Trump I would vote for him again in
certain circumstances so I'm just
putting it out there that hopefully some
good people will get involved and just
watch what the media does to them
speaking of all of that uh on Friday I
interviewed Mike Pompeo former Secretary
of State former head of the CIA who
everyone is saying is going to run I
actually did ask him that obviously at
the end uh and part one will be out
today the full thing will be out today
at
reubenreport.locals.com and as long as
we're talking about presidents I thought
we could wrap up today's show with the
former president a guy that that
Margaret Thatcher knew quite well uh
here is just a snippet of Ronald
Reagan's farewell
address this is uh 1988 his farewell
address and uh well a bit inspirational
to end the show today I've spoken of The
Shining City all my political life but I
don't know if I ever quite communicated
what I saw when I said it but in my mind
it was a tall proud City built on rocks
stronger than oceans Windswept God
blessed and teeming with people of all
kinds living in Harmony and peace a city
with pre-ports that hummed with Commerce
and creativity and if there had to be
City walls the walls had doors and the
doors were open to anyone with the will
and the heart to get here that's how I
saw it and see it still and as I walk
off into the city streets
final word to the men and women of the
Reagan Revolution the men and women
across America who for eight years did
the work that brought America back my
friends we did it we weren't just
marking time
we made a difference we made the city
stronger we made the city Freer and we
left it in good hands all in all not bad
not bad at all
not bad at all I think we can get back
to that I don't think it's that complex
I think there are forces working against
us we have we have clownish ridiculous
politicians in this country and we have
evil lizard-like people meeting halfway
across the world to decide how we should
live but I think we can defeat all of
them I think the truth shall set you
free and I think the the founding
documents of this country are strong
enough we just need good people to get
involved and whether that means run for
president or do whatever the hell it is
that you're doing in your life to not be
part of the madness that really really
is the answer guys it's Monday which
means that it's meme Monday over at the
Reuben report Community here's the one
that I put up this morning I saw this
one over the weekend thought this was
pretty funny college kids after
graduating and seeing the taxes from
their first check right so they morph
slowly from Bernie Sanders into Rand
Paul which of course is very similar to
the you know if you're not a liberal in
your 20s you have no heart and if you're
not a conservative in your 30s you have
no brain some some version of that all
right we got a post game show coming up
in about 55 seconds if you have not
subscribed knowing that YouTube's
probably not very happy with me please
do subscribe at rumble.com reubenreport
and uh head on over to locals right now
and we will continue the madness happy
Monday everybody see you tomorrow
28 year old Bridget Klein Simpson has
identified as a woman for years and she
wants to get into better shape so she
went to the Bodyworks gym for women in
Parksville for a membership Clem Simpson
says she was initially welcomed but
after one workout she was informed she
was not allowed at the woman's only gym
saying sorry we made a mistake you're
not actually allowed to be here but
you're more than welcome to use the
co-ed facility and uh I kind of just
hung up because uh I was I mean I was
extremely extra
devastated I mean there's really no
other word for it
[Music]